what is it to be a hero
hero isn't someone who lives above us
they live among us always here but
rarely recognized this is your Hell's
Kitchen welcome home
I won't ever wanted to see what's about
to happen
just trying to make my city a better
place
would you put day drinking under
experience or special skills job
yo I don't like it so what you think
you're gonna do man
you want to go to war I'll take you to
war let's start now
Hell's Kitchen is about to explode
this is going to be more fun than I
thought more words getting around about
other people you've helped
I want to believe in what you're doing
but if you want justice you have to get
it yourself you're absolutely right
when rounding the jammer bang
you
you think the four of you can save New
York you can't even save yourselves
you
come as you are youtubers I haven't
heard that song and so long we finally
got an official teaser trailer for
defenders so let's break it down really
important thing first so stick says the
four of you saved the city so obviously
he's not talking about the Punisher
because technically there be five but
yes Punisher will totally participate in
defenders in some way they'll explain
what's going on with him and they did
explain at the Luke Cage panel that they
were officially working on a Punisher
series but they don't have a premiere
date for that yet
they just teased it like Jon Bernthal
was like hey everybody how's it going
thanks so much and then kind of took off
as they were starting the actual Luke
Cage panel but a lot of this Netflix
defenders stuff was set up was organized
way before they knew they had a really
awesome Punisher on their hands so I
think they're doing everything they can
to integrate him into their plan but you
kind of see them hit the beats with all
these characters the voiceover is Karen
Page who as of the end of daredevil
season 2 is working for the paper so
she'll be talking about the heroes on
the street you know helping things that
she'll be kind of like their voice to
the public because like Luke Cage for
instance whenever his series picks up
he'll be in hiding because of what
happened during Jessica Jones series
they had that big conversation about
doing the quote-unquote hero thing you
know jessica jones was like you know
what was your experience with all this
and Luke Cage just says the trouble
follows so he's trying to keep as low
profile as possible so you can kind of
see the arc that the characters have
over there first you know in the case of
daredevil it's two series they decide to
take up the cult like the answer the
call they decide to become a hero and
use their abilities to help people so
that's gonna happen for Luke Cage during
his series then we'll meet iron fist and
we'll learn all about him now I'll talk
a little bit more about iron fist when I
do an iron fist video later but the
other voice that you hear at the end of
this the stakes that you know the four
of you think you can save the city you
can barely save yourselves and a lot of
you are asking who is the villain then
so remember at the end of daredevil
season two when things really got crazy
with all the ninjas the hand was
resurrecting Elektra and it was implied
that she'd be possessed by this demon
spirit so it seems like she in the hand
will be the villains for the defender
series pending what happens during the
Iron Fist series and also the other big
tip-off here is that this logo here like
the peel-off logo is a city skyline
transposed with a very big
and as in the hand organization of all
these crazy ninjas that are resurrecting
a demon so a bit of a tip-off there
daredevil season 2 only teased kind of
with that mystic realm Iron Fist will
fully go there so when a lot of the
stick scenes when we seen him talking
about things you know between the chased
and the hand this greater war that he's
trying to get daredevil tied up in that
that will be what's going on during
defenders so I think that's gonna have
something to do with black sky the hand
and they'll just push deeper into that
and iron fist but for those of you
wondering when this is gonna drop
obviously iron fist is going to be
dropping sometime in the spring you know
around when daredevil season 2 premiered
earlier this year defenders will be
after that so I'm expecting that
sometime during the summer but just
generally speaking it's about a year
away so they'll start promoting Luke
Cage Moors we get closer to the
September 30th premiere of that series
the next year you'll start seeing them
hype Iron Fist up then we'll really
start seeing some defenders stuff and
they've already confirmed Jessica Jones
Season 2 daredevil season 3 in the
Punisher series so all that stuff will
happen after defenders and I think
Jessica Jones season 2 will probably be
the next thing but it all just depends
on when they start shooting and I
believe they've already been filming for
defenders most of the footage in this
trailer is actually taken from the other
series like you see footage from
daredevil season 2 there's some footage
from Jessica Jones season 1 there's some
footage from Luke Cage which actually
hasn't premiered yet but you get the
idea and this is really awesome looking
at this collage here there's Easter eggs
all over it the daredevil cross devil of
Hell's Kitchen
alias investigations for Jessica Jones
Cicotte prison for Luke Cage and then
Danny ran for iron fist if you're
wondering why I took their Nirvana song
out it's just for copyright reasons mute
music is a big problem on YouTube so
better safe than sorry but it's just
come as you are meaning that all of them
are just like these broken heroes like
stick says you can barely protect
yourselves
so they have to find a way to come
together to save their city the Avengers
have actually moved upstate to the new
facility as of Captain America Civil War
so it's not like they're just chilling
in Midtown and the defenders can go ask
them for help
so giant mystical war breaks out all
over New York City only the defenders
can save the day but let me know like
what do you guys want to see in that
defender series keeping the mine that
they've already shot a lot of it but
there'll be a lot of internal Easter
eggs for you know defenders things from
the comics people that belong to the
defenders I know Doctor Strange was part
of the defender
but I'm not expecting any crossover
between him I think that the movies are
gonna be relatively separate the Netflix
stuff will probably relatively
self-contained
hopefully what I'm hoping is is that
they gain the rights to do spider-man II
strake so they could do like Daily Bugle
they could do New York things even if
spider-man's not gonna be in it so
because we're still about a year away
from this dropping I'm not expecting
like a big defenders trailer to come
again for a while
they will be posting a lot more Luke
Cage stuff as we get closer so I will be
doing more Luke Cage videos in the
future and of course I'm gonna be doing
regular episode videos like I did for
Jessica Jones and for daredevil season 2
so no worries there it's gonna be a lot
of fun and there is a Marvel giveaway
going on this week so just a reminder
that all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video I'm probably gonna wait to post my
Iron Fist video till early Friday
morning just because I've already posted
so many videos it's still Thursday as
I'm making this video right now so no
worries I'll just put links for
everything in the description while you
guys wait for my next video to post you
can click here for my Luke Cage trailer
breakdown and you can click here for all
my other comic-con videos thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight